a school in kiev evacuated as bomb
disposal teams searched the building a
training exercise this time but schools
across ukraine have been plagued with
false alarm bomb scares being blamed on
russian agents
the ukrainians have obviously got to
carry out these kind of drills because
there could be more bomb scares but this
is doing nothing obviously to calm
already pretty jittery nerves in the
city
in the corridors of power in the offices
of the president his advisor told me a
russian invasion isn't imminent but
russian agents are inside the country
and creating division and fear
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
to mayor of kiev from boris johnson yeah
across town kiev's mayor and boxing
champion vitali klitschko showed me the
book boris johnson gave him the prince
machiavelli's manual on the dark arts of
power
has that been useful for you as mayor of
kiev yes of course
ukrainians he says will use everything
they have to defend themselves we don't
have another choice
we have to defend our country
defend our future defend our families
we are not aggressive we have to defend
the future of our children
but ukraine needs more help from allies
he says ridiculing germany's promise to
send five thousand helmets and
questioning what side it's on
it's
this joke
germans have to decide in which side
if ukraine defend
our
independency
international integrity
or in the sight of aggressors
ukrainians must watch and wait while the
diplomacy goes on miles away from here
in the meantime
preparing for the worst
dominic waghorn sky news kiev